[Music]
you started a musical theater crass all
right now I would think is there did you
feel it all like there was a stigma if
you're a boy and you and you're saying I
want to get into musical yeah it wasn't
as cool as some TV shows and movies have
made it seem nowadays it was a little
lame to do theater as you can imagine so
I I starts nowadays there's so many
shows that like Glee they make it seem
like all the cool guys exactly exactly
so I I was actually coming back from a
junior high school basketball practice
my mom bribed me with a really delicious
meal in the neighboring town I think she
knew I had an itch to do some musical
theater and seeing I've always saying so
basically I went in there saying happy
birthday because I wasn't prepared I had
my basketball uniform on she took you
right and she didn't tell you it was
going on she just took you from
basketball practice said I'll take you
this audition and you'll get an Italian
meal out of it yeah yeah and I was yeah
that's how easily persuaded I am so I
went there I had full basketball uniform
sweaty and I realized this is the plot
to High School Musical but I swear my my
thing came first no you stole the oh no
even a real anecdote no I like Zac Efron
but his characters a jerk because he
totally stole my thing and I went in
there and by default I got the male lead
because there were no other males right
and I wasn't nice to know you're the
only guy audition something if the
competition was zilch so I went in there
and I got the role of Jesus because it
was for it was for Godspell oh yeah
so we rang for Jesus I thought for a
minute it was I got confused and I
thought it was for high school musical
no no and that Jesus is in it yeah right
Jesus has that make out see ya hit a
sequel yeah but yeah so I sang for Jesus
it's the second most impressive Jesus
story right and and then I was bitten by
the bug in my life you know changed it
was a 180 and now I'm I'm here right so
thank God for that amazing bribery but
your mom yeah your mom made you do this
thanks MA
thank you mom after we all got to thank
our mods it's true
we have tell us a little bit about the
show ground floor okay so ground floor
it's a it's a really fun sitcom it's
it's a little love story mixed in with
an ensemble comedy so it's a workplace
comedy and there's a lot of differences
between the top floor executives and the
ground floor maintenance you're an
executive I'm an executive and I fall in
love with one of the girls on the
maintenance staff okay so it's a little
bit of a class you know it happens yeah
trust me yeah oh yeah I'll tell you more
later I've heard yeah someone I'm not
gonna tell my wife horrible thing to say
on TV
and yet it's done let's take a look at
this clip from ground floor okay the
point is I made a client a million
dollars overnight damn who is that guy
sounds cute well I do not know but I am
sure client number zero zero zero six
nine one four three two five one three
four a be one two one six one nine nine
three will have a smile on his or her or
their face snooze flash you're boring oh
really
boring is it also boring that I crushed
the Russell small-cap index by over
fifteen yeah okay I hear myself
[Applause]